alleged pedophile Jeffrey Epstein heads
for jail NBC outs mitch mcconnell's
great-great-grandfather as a slave owner
and we are forced by law to talk about
women's soccer for like the 100th
consecutive day I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
I know I'm excited to talk about women's
soccer aren't you I mean just what I
love doing every single day but
apparently that's what's in the news so
we'll have to do that I'll get to that
in just a little bit but the big story
of the day continues to be the arrest of
Jeffrey Epstein for folks who have not
been following this long-running and
horrifying story Jeffrey Epstein is a
billionaire financier it's pretty
unclear where he came up with his
billions but the dude is worth a fortune
he also happens to be an alleged
pedophile according to Ali Watkins and
Vivian Wang over the weekend
federal prosecutors resurrected a
federal sex crimes case against
billionaire financier Jeffrey Epstein by
focusing on accusations that he sexually
assaulted girls at his mansion in
Manhattan more than a decade after a
widely criticized plea deal shielded him
from similar charges in Florida federal
prosecutors unsealed the new charges on
Monday accusing Epstein 66 of running a
sex trafficking operation that lured
dozens of underage girls some as young
as 14 to his Upper East Side home and to
a mansion in Palm Beach Florida
according to an indictment Epstein who
is 66 is accused of engaging in sex acts
with minors some as young as 14 years
old during naked massage sessions then
paying them hundreds of dollars in cash
according to the indictment he also
asked some of the girls to recruit other
underage girls in other words this guy
is one of the worst pieces of crap in
the modern history of the country he was
engaged in sexual trafficking of minors
which is about as bad as it gets
everyone involved with him should go to
jail for extraordinary periods of time
because this is horrifying in every way
the indictment says Epstein created a
vast network of underage victims for him
to sexually exploit in locations
including New York and Palm Beach
Epstein was arrested on Saturday at
Teterboro Airport in New Jersey after
arriving on a private flight from France
to law enforcement officials said he's
charged with sex trafficking and sex
trafficking conspiracy he faces a
combined maximum sentence of up to 45
years in prison if convicted prosecutors
are also seeking the forfeiture of
Epstein's townhouse on East 71st Street
the new charges according to The Times
are a revival of a years long case
against Epstein who faced similar
accusations involving girls who told the
police they were brought to his mansion
in South Florida and then assaulted that
case unraveled in 2008 after Epstein was
offered a secret plea deal by federal
prosecutors one of whom is now the
Secretary of Labor under President Trump
and this is where the case starts to
become important for modern politics
there are two aspects of the case that
are important for modern politics aspect
number one is the involvement of the
current Secretary of Labor who is the
prosecutor in this case and who cut a
really really sweet plea deal with
Jeffrey Epstein that prevented all of
the information in the indictments from
going public and ended up protecting
Jeffrey Epstein in a variety of ways
that he served a very soft sentence for
what are obviously horrific crimes we'll
get to that in just one second first
hiren used to be rough not anymore when
someone makes the slightest most minor
insignificant mistake here on the bench
Shapiro show they know how easily we can
replace them
thanks to zip recruiters simpler keeps
our employees frightened and also
productive zip recruiters dot-com /
daily wired go check them out right now
zip recruiter sends your job posting to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
they don't stop there as applications
come in the zip recruiter analyzes every
single one spotlights the top candidates
so you're never going to miss a great
match zipper career is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that's zip recruiter comm slash Dai
ly WI re the zip recruiters come slash
daily wear by the way we don't just use
it in order so we can threaten our
employees with firing we also use it
when we need new employees who are
awesome and that's why you should use it
recruiter to zip record comm slash daily
wire zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire go check them out
right now and try them out for free at
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire ok
so as I say there are two reasons why
the Epstein scandal is important for
today's politics reason number one has
to do with the Secretary of Labor whose
name is Alexander Acosta under President
Trump he was a prosecutor in the apps
team case the second reason is all of
the rich and powerful people the Jeffrey
Epstein knew and who are now being
dragged into the conversation about who
knew what when who might have been
involved because apparently Epstein used
to traffic these girls to friends that's
one of the allegations so the Washington
Post reports today and the indictment on
Monday of Jeffrey Epstein on sex
trafficking charges has reignited
questions about the way Alexander Acosta
and now president Trump's labor
secretary
handled
earlier case against Epstein that
resulted in a minimal sentence as US
attorney in Florida in 2007 Acosta
negotiated a plea deal that led to two
felony solicitation charges and 13
months in county jail for Epstein the
billionaire financier was allowed to
work from his office for six days a week
Epstein had been facing the possibility
of life in prison pretty rich deal right
there his alleged victims were not even
told about the deal on Monday in the
indictment ition in federal court in New
York
Epstein faced charges resulting from
allegations like those in the Florida
case the indictment says that in both
New York and Florida Epstein perpetuated
this abuse in similar ways accosted
through a spokesperson declined to
comment Labor Department spokesperson
Robert bazoo doe referred questions
about Acosta's role in the plea deal to
the Justice Department Justice
Department spokesperson then declined to
comment this was very controversial
because Miami Herald had done a
long-running series about exactly what
happened here and it appeared that this
was a sweetheart deal for Jeffrey
Epstein who called in favors from
friends who then called in prosecutors
that at least was the allegation made by
the newspapers in in Florida officials
at the White House are nervous that
Democrats will encourage women allegedly
abused by Epstein to testify publicly
before Congress drawing attention to
Acosta's work on the plea deal President
Trump right now has no media plan to
force out or fire Acosta like others
officials are speaking on condition of
anonymity a senior White House official
said the administration would like to
learn the contents of a Justice
Department inquiry into a costume before
making any decision so there is already
a DOJ
inquiry on all of this House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi of course says that Acosta
should step down she's doing so
precipitously because we still don't
know all of the information but if it is
true that things are as bad as they
appear there's no question that Acosta
should step down I mean if it turns out
that he cut a sweetheart deal on the
basis of something corrupt not only
should he step down it should be
disbarred obviously maybe there may be a
prosecution in the works if corruption
was involved Acosta has not been
summoned to testify before Congress
specifically on the matter the only
person who asked him about all of this
at his confirmation hearing in 2017 was
senator Tim Kaine of Virginia Acosta
told Kane the professionals within a
prosecutor's office decided on the deal
taking himself out of the negotiations
this wasn't my deal in the first place
two House Democrats said the party now
has more leverage to demand that a cost
to testify Jamie Raskin Democrat of
Maryland he said in the wake of the New
York charges there is resurgent interest
in hearing from him about the dual
system of justice in Florida Acosta has
some major reckoning to do several
Republican members of Congress had they
supported Acosta or reserving judgment
about the labor secretary pending the
DOJ inquiry at this point senator roy
blunt he said if there's more that comes
out i'll be glad to look at it at this
point I think it's been looked at
repeatedly I think everybody has reached
the same conclusion there is a Justice
Department Office of Professional
Responsibility they investigate
misconduct of Department employees
opened an ethics investigation in
February and so whether it's attorneys
committed professional misconduct in
pursuing the plea deal in the first
place it is unclear at this point how
this is going to result
Acosta's initial handling of the case
was widely criticized he signed off on a
deal in which in exchange for guilty
pleas in state court to solicitation
Epstein served a 13-month sentence
registered as a sex offender and paid
restitution to certain victims the deal
was initially sealed keeping it secret
until it was released as part of a 2015
lawsuit in addition while the Florida
investigation initially came to the
attention of authorities because of a 14
year olds alleged victim the only minor
Epstein was convicted of soliciting was
16 years old according to the Washington
Post that age difference eased his
obligations to register as a sex
offender in 2011 Acosta again the
Secretary of Labor wrote a letter
seeking to explain his reasoning saying
he faced a year-long assault on the
prosecution and prosecutors by an army
of legal superstars he also wrote the
defense lawyers investigated individual
prosecutors and their families looking
for personal peccadilloes that may
provide a basis for disqualification
again I think there's gonna be a lot
more information that comes out right
here and we will find out as time goes
on suffice it to say that with all of
this swirling Acosta should certainly be
thinking about whether it is good for
the administration for him to remain and
whether the Trump administration should
have to bear the burden of a case that
seems pretty obviously wrongly
negotiated in the first place that is
angle number one and folks are jumping
all over at angle number two is that
Epstein had a lot of rich and powerful
friends with whom he's to hobnob and two
of those friends were Bill Clinton and
Donald Trump
and so there is all sorts of speculation
today that either one of those men is
involved in these sorts of sexual
activities with women or girls who are
underage and that speculation obviously
is based also on the reputation of the
two men both of whom are famous
womanisers according to the Associated
Press Jeffrey Epstein is hobnob with
some of the world's most powerful people
during his jet-setting life future
president Donald Trump called him a
terrific guy former President Bill
Clinton praised his intellect and
philanthropic efforts and was a frequent
flyer aboard his private jet the rest of
the billionaire financier on child sex
trafficking charges is raising questions
about how much is high-powered
associates knew about the hedge fund
managers interactions with underage
girls and whether they turned a blind
eye to potentially illegal conduct and
of course it is putting additional
scrutiny on Alex Acosta as we have
pointed out
Kellyanne Conway told reporters at the
White House that the president has not
talked to Epstein in 10 or 15 years she
said like everyone else Trump sees the
charges against Epstein is completely
unconscionable and obviously criminal
disgusting Conway also defended Acosta
saying that the the actual perpetrator
here is Jeffrey Epstein the only major
comment that has ever been given to date
that we know about from Trump about
Epstein is a comments in New York
magazine in 2002 in which he said that
he had known Epstein for 15 years and
praised him as a terrific guy saying
quote he's a lot of fun to be with and
his even said that he likes beautiful
women as much as I do and many of them
are on the younger side which is not a
great thing to say about a guy who's an
alleged pedophile no doubt about it
Jeffery enjoys his social life Trump
Organization attorney Alan Garten has
since distanced Trump from Epstein
telling political in 2017 Trump quote
had no relationship with mr. evidence
but with mr. Epstein and had no
knowledge whatsoever of his conduct and
Trump said he didn't know anything about
all of this now that's the Trump of it
and then we get to the Clinton uh but
we'll get to that in just one second
first I tell you something about my rake
on earbuds they are just awesome not
only do they sound good not only do they
look at it and even have little stems
that you get in comparable products but
they cost like half the price of any
other premium wireless earbuds on the
market and they sound just as amazing
rate Kanzi fifty wireless earbuds are a
game changer they're so comfortable and
they are easy to take anywhere unlike
some of your other wireless options ray
con earbuds are both stylish and
discreet
if no dangling wires or stems and of
course they don't just look great they
sound great as well
rake on offers their wireless earbuds
for everyone in a range of fun colors at
an unbeatable price go to buy rake on
Comm slash men get 20% off your order
right now
that's bu y ra y co n comm slash man for
20% off your rake on wireless earbuds
they're awesome which is why I wear them
pretty much everywhere I mean I'm
listening to content all day long and
Reiko not only makes that possible they
do it with style and in a cost you can
afford if you've been eyeing a pair now
is the time to get an amazing deal one
more time it's by breakin comm slash pen
Bui RA Y Co n comm slash pen go check
them out get amazing ear buds for like
half the price by Ray cons comm slash
madmen okay so one of the names
mentioned was Donald Trump and again
there's been no actual accusation that
Donald Trump was involved in any of
these activities other than he knew
Epstein and so the question becomes did
he know what Epstein was doing should he
have said something if he did know but
again we have no evidence of any of that
we just have Trump sort of mouthing off
to New York Magazine in 2002 which is
yucky but not exactly indicative that
Trump knew that Epstein was trafficking
in fourteen-year-old girls there's a
difference between icky and gross
President Trump has plenty of experience
with icky and gross when it comes to his
treatment of the ladies there's a
difference between that and knowing that
somebody is an actual sex trafficker of
underage women and then there's Bill
Clinton so Epstein was also an associate
of Bill Clinton's repeatedly lending the
former president his jet to travel
overseas flight logs obtained by Fox
News showed the former President took at
least 26 trips aboard Epstein's Boeing
727 nicknamed the Lolita Express from
2001 to 2003 it's never good to ride
around on a plane called the Lolita
Express guys it's always kind of a bad
move that included extended junkets
around the world with Epstein and fellow
travelers fellow passengers identified
on manifest by their initials or first
names including Tatiana
according to the outlet Clinton told New
York magazine through spokesman for that
same 2002 story quote Jeffrey is both a
highly successful financier and a
committed philanthropist with a keen
sense of global markets and an in-depth
knowledge of 21st century science I
especially appreciated his insights and
generosity during the recent trip to
Africa to work on democratization
empowering the poor citizen service and
combating HIV
ADEs Clinton spokesperson angel Urena
said the former president knows nothing
about the terrible crimes Jeffrey
Epstein pleaded guilty to in Florida
some years ago or those with which he
has been recently charged in New York he
said in 2002 and 2003 Clinton took four
trips on Epstein's plane with multiple
stops and that staff and his Secret
Service detail traveled on every leg so
the claim is that the discrepancy
between tension between 26 flights and
four trips is that a trip can include
multiple flights and so it was four
trips and Secret Service was there and
thus this was not Clinton flying over to
Lolita Island or sex-slave Island and
then participating in the in the
proceeds of evil ureña said he has not
spoken to Epstein in well over a decade
has never been to little st. James
Island Epstein's ranch in New Mexico or
his residence in Florida all of this is
extraordinarily ugly of course and it
does raise questions about whether we
have a dual-track of justice in the
United States for folks who are
exorbitantly wealthy the answer of
course is yes we'll get to that in just
one second
so there are also accusations that this
story was well known by the media and
that a cover-up basically took place
including by major editors over a
democracy now which is a far left
website they did an interview with Vicki
ward who's an investigative journalist
who profiled Epstein for Vanity Fair in
2003 and a piece headlined the talented
mr. Epstein the magazine's editor at the
time according to Democracy Now that
editor named Graydon Carter cut out the
testimonies of two young women Epstein
allegedly molested who had spoken to
Vicki Ward on the record one of them
underage word wrote about what happened
with her Epstein reporting for The Daily
Beast
in an article headline I tried to warn
you about sleazy billionaire Jeffrey
Epstein in 2003 and here is what she
wrote about this this year the piece was
update was originally published in 2015
updated as of yesterday
Vicki Ward says Jeffrey wanted me to
tell you that you looked so pretty the
female voice said ins my disbelieving
ear it was the fall of 2002 I was
pregnant uncomfortably so for the first
time in with twins do the following
March I was besieged by a relentless
morning sickness I was sick in street
gutters on to my desk at 10:00 with
friends I suffered severe bloating and
water retention but here was this faux
compliment coming bizarrely in a bit
grotesque
from a wooden woodland I hadn't met a
female assistant who worked for one
Jeffrey Epstein a mysterious Gadsby
esketh financier who might been assigned
to write about by my then boss Graydon
Carter the editor of Vanity Fair upon
hearing of my assignment Epstein had
invited me to an off-the-record tea in
his Upper East Side house during which I
distinctly remember avoiding the finger
food and then had his assistant call to
tell me he thought I'd pretty I was
pretty at first it was the early stages
of reporting I was amused it having been
so crassly underestimated for a man who
clearly considered himself a
sophisticated ladies man the only book
he'd left out for me to see was a
paperback by the Marquis de Sade that's
a hell of a tactic
I thought his journalist seduction
technique was a bit like his table
manners entire need of improvement if
only it had ended there this was what it
had been meant to be a gossipy piece
about a shadowy slightly sinister but
essentially harmless man who preferred
track pants to suits but somehow live
very large had wealthy important friends
hung out with models and shied away from
the press but it didn't I haven't ever
wanted to go back and dwell on that sour
time but then the latest epstein scandal
broke this is circa 2015 when Prince
Andrew was accused in a Florida Court
filing of having sex with a 17 year old
girl while she was a sex slave of
Epstein's in the last 48 hours I've had
a journalist from the UK Sun newspaper
put herself inside my for a I've been
inundated with requests for TV
interviews Epstein's old mentor the
convicted fraudster Steven Hoffenberg
recently released from jail after a
20-year sentence had been pestering me
and my agent to write a movie separately
Hoffenberg daughter has gotten in touch
and it's gotten me thinking they're
summoned justices maybe only time can
write perhaps now is the time and Vicky
Ward goes on to talk about how all of
this gossip was starting to emerge how
she talked with at least a couple of
underage girls who accused Epstein of
engaging in criminal activity and how
all of this was basically silenced by
Graydon Carter how Graydon Carter had
her cut all of this out of the story now
all of this does speak to something
deeply ugly about the halls of power in
American life about the the reason that
there are so many people who are who are
suspicious of exactly how our criminal
justice system works
Epstein speaks to all of those things
Epstein speaks to it to all of those
things and
it does go to our perceptions of how
justice ought to be done in the United
States it does raise questions about how
justice ought to be pursued now that
does not mean that people are being over
prosecuted if they are poor it does mean
that people are being under prosecuted
if they are richer there's a difference
between the two accusations it's more of
that in just one second first let me
talk to you about starting daily wire so
when we started daily wire we had to
expend an enormous amounts of energy an
enormous amount of capital and one of
the ways you end up spending a lot of
capital is on your legal costs but you
don't have to one of the best resources
to help you run your business is Legal
Zoom Legal Zoom was created eighteen
years ago to help all Americans
confidently get past the hurdles that
come with owning a business since then
over 2 million people have trusted Legal
Zoom to help start or run their
businesses whether you have questions
about incorporating or forming an LLC if
you need tax advice contracts reviewed
or info on trademarks their network of
independent attorneys and professionals
can provide the guidance you need the
best part is you won't get charged by
the hour because Legal Zoom is not a law
firm let Legal Zoom help out with your
small business worries so you can focus
on what you do best
visit legalzoom.com right now and use
promo code been and check out for
special savings that's legalzoom.com
promo code been LegalZoom where life
meets legal go check them out at Legal
Zoom calm I'm a lawyer and I've been
using noodles in myself for years they
just have great legal resources you're
not gonna have to spend an arm and a leg
to get your business started or make it
more efficient check them out right now
at legalzoom.com
and use promo code Ben at checkout
legalzoom.com ok so let's talk about
this dual track of Justice so there's an
accusation that's been made by Elizabeth
Bruning who is a sort of interesting
columnist for The Washington Post and
she talks at length very often about her
sort of perception of wealth and what
she says about this case is that this is
an obvious case of rich people
solidarity and basically rich people
decided to overlook all of this because
they are rich and that the best way to
read this case is banality of banality
of evil among rich people who see class
solidarity as the as the thing that
really matters like she said she tweeted
out this morning if you want to see
class loyalty transcend partisan divides
just look
get who rich liberal politicians hang
out with when they think that you aren't
paying attention well yes and no yes and
no the fact is that rich people do tend
to hang out with rich people just like
people who are poor tend to tend to hang
out with people who are poor all the
institutions that used to bridge that
gap have basically been destroyed in
American life one of the institutions
that was chief and bridging that gap was
the church where people don't really
check each other's income I go to a
synagogue every Saturday I really don't
know the income of the people I go to
synagogue with nor do I care because
we're there to participate in the same
activity a lot of these sort of societal
building institutions that cross class
lines happen in religious contexts they
don't tend to happen in social contexts
they don't tend to happen in educational
context per se because if you go to Yale
chances are that everybody you're going
to school with is going to be rich in
ten years with all of that said the idea
that rich people are backing each other
up because they are rich that is an
overreach of the situation it does mean
however that they are in contact with
other people who are rich and powerful
on a regular basis and Epstein was
giving lots of money to various
charities including cancer charities in
Harvard University and this put him in
contact with a lot of very rich and
powerful people so when he was in
trouble he could pick up the phone and a
lot of those people were on speed dial
wealth does come with power there's no
question that that is true but this is
why what happened with Alex Acosta
really matters because this is where the
prosecutors are supposed to say no this
is where the prosecutors are supposed to
say listen you can hire the best
attorneys you can call all your powerful
friends but we stand for the people this
is why prosecution is not the victim
versus the perpetrator prosecution is
instead the people versus every case in
state prosecution courts is the people
versus you're supposed to be
representing the people of a particular
state and that means that you're not
supposed to be cutting sweetheart deals
this is why I think what comes out from
the DOJ about Acosta's involvement in
the sweetheart deal is much more
important than all of the people that
Epstein was hobnobbing with if you can't
prove that any of those people were
actively engaged in sex trafficking then
I think casting aspersions at them that
they were quote-unquote probably engaged
in sex trafficking isn't appropriate I
think that's true whether you're talking
about Donald Trump or whether you're
talking about Bill Clinton like is it
suspicious that all these guys were
flying around without
epstein or Jeffrey Epstein rather yeah
of course that's suspicious but does
that mean that we can immediately say
that these guys were involved in the
same sorts of activities no it doesn't
mean that at all it turns out that when
you're hanging out with rich people all
the time some of those rich people are
probably going to be criminals and that
is true no matter which class you are in
virtually everybody knows somebody who
has committed a crime and when you're
very wealthy then you are a
philanthropist and you're trying to buy
access for your business which is
basically why Bill Clinton was getting
flown around in 2002-2003
well then presumably you're going to
come into contact with a lot of very
powerful and corrupt people so I would
put the Clinton in from stuff off to one
side and I would put the the Secretary
of Labor questions on another page
entirely but suffice it to say it'll be
it'll be fascinating to watch as all of
this unfolds fascinating and horrifying
and the real question is whether our
state prosecutors are doing their job
that is the only question in the end
that really matters here if there's no
evidence that any of these other rich
and powerful people were involved in
this sort of criminal activity okay
meanwhile the media doing yeoman's work
on behalf of stupid so if they own stock
and stupid they are doing a wonderful
job
it is so obvious truly obvious what many
members of the media do have is their
agenda so let's take NBC News as an
example so NBC News yesterday launches
the most bizarre stupid story I may have
seen in in modern American history
that's saying a lot
if they watch the story yesterday from
Meet the Press and the title did this
quote Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell's great-great-grandfather's
owned fourteen slaves bringing
reparations issue close to home and then
there's a graphic of Mitch McConnell
looking somber next to a bunch of text
from slave sales from 1859 1860 with the
signatures of his great-great
grandfather's so this is now news then
we are going to go back a hundred and
sixty years and dig up who your
great-great grandfather's were and then
use that to
browbeat you into taking a position on
slavery reparations that you do not hold
Meet the Press reports details about
McConnell's ancestors discovered by NBC
News through a search of ancestry and
census records came in the wake of
recent hearings on reparations before
the House Judiciary Subcommittee on the
Constitution civil rights and civil
liberties well it's not quite that that
has happened here color me a little bit
suspicious when it comes to NB C
dropping this news because immediately
after this news drops I mean immediately
within 24 hours and twelve hours of that
news dropping last night that's not news
by the way
hey great-great grandpa did something is
not news it was news in like 1855 it is
not news in 2019 because mister McConnel
it turns out he was not alive when his
great-great grandfather's were in fact
he was not a glint in their eye as of
yet but apparently he is guilty of all
of their sins and this is really what's
infusing his opposition to slavery
reparations obviously it is the fact
that he carries that slave owner blood
within him that is infusing his deep and
abiding hatred for slavery reparations
because deep within his DNA is buried
slaveholding now what makes this kinda
weird
what makes that report kind of weird
just in terms of timing is the fact that
literally thin 12 hours Aimee McGrath
who ran for Congress in Kentucky just
last year in 2018 announced that she was
running against Mitch McConnell so weird
within 12 hours of this stupid bit of
Apple research which is a terrible dumb
bit of Oppo research dropping within 12
hours he has a challenger and a
challenger who ran in an R + 9 district
and lost by 3 she's gonna get crushed ok
the state of Kentucky went for Donald
Trump by something like 30 points so she
has no shot at all in this race the
media nonetheless are playing this up
there didn't give her the beta overall
treatment
Amy McGrath she is a retired fighter
pilot she also happens to be a person
who has called herself the most
progressive legislative mind in the
state of Kentucky so good luck with that
one
the media are pumping her up and the way
they're doing that is by dredging up
information about Mitch McConnell's
great-great-great-grandfather hit the
pieces by Corky ATSA mask oh and here's
the idiotic piece says Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell who said recently
he opposes paying government reparations
to the descendants of American slaves
has a family history deeply entwined in
the issue two of his great-great
grandfather's were slave owners a US
census records show two
great-great-grandfather's James
McConnell and Richard Daley owned a
total of at least fourteen slaves in
limestone County Alabama all but two of
them female according to the county
slave schedules in the 1850 and 1860
censuses the details about McConnell's
ancestors discovered by NBC News the
research of ancestry and census records
came in the wake of recent hearings on
reparations McConnell said he was
opposed to the idea argument would be
hard to figure out whom to compensate
I don't think reparations for something
that happened 150 years ago well none of
us currently living are responsible is a
good idea he said On June 14th we've
tried to deal with our original sin of
slavery by fighting a civil war by
passing landmark civil rights
legislation we've elected an
african-american president NBC News and
several phone calls and emails to
McConnell's office asked if the senator
was aware that his great-great
grandfather's were slave owners the
office did not respond to those requests
nor should they because that's stupid
crap you know honestly this is where
we're going we're gonna track down
everybody's four generations removed
ancestors and determine what crimes they
committed this is how we decide all of
this now there's some obvious problems
with with this particular angle namely
that a lot of people you wouldn't expect
have slaveholders in the family tree
take for example Kamala Harris here's a
piece from her father Donald J Harris
who's a professor over at Stanford quote
my roots go back within my lifetime to
my paternal grandmother miss Chrissy
Nate Kristina Brown descendant of
Hamilton Brown who's on record as
plantation and slave owner and founder
of Browns town and to my maternal
grandfather my maternal grandmother miss
iris so it turns out that you know who
else has slave holder blood running in
her veins presumably if we're using the
same metrics as Mitchell McConnell
is Kamala Harris but I guess Komal
Harris is off scot-free because she has
the right politics that's how this works
so a thing for which you are not
responsible we used to have this thing
in America where you weren't supposed to
judge somebody
based on an immutable characteristic
like their race for example the level of
melanin in their skin
based on their ancestry you weren't
supposed to judge people based on that
but apparently you can if they hold the
wrong political positions so Mitch
McConnell opposes slavery reparations he
has a great - great-great grandfather's
who were slaveholders that's probably
why he's doing this because he wants to
avoid paying eighty thousand dollars or
something in taxes that that's obviously
why Mitch McConnell is doing all of this
and Kamala Harris gets off scot-free
because Kamala Harris of course while
she has slave holders in the family tree
she's in favor of reparations that means
she's uh but this does raise some weird
questions about Barack Obama who as it
turns out used to oppose slavery
reparations like in 2008 he came out and
he said openly that he was opposed to
slavery reparations so what do we do at
the fact that Barack Obama has you
guessed it slaveholders in his family
tree and listen to how the Baltimore Sun
covered this twist on Obama's family
history at the time this is more
appropriate coverage but here is how the
coverage was done about Barack Obama
versus NBC News doing it about Mitch
McConnell quote many people know the
Democratic presidential candidate Barack
Obama's father was from Kenya and his
mother was from Kansas but an intriguing
sliver of his family history has
received almost no attention until now
it appears that forebears of his white
mother owned slaves according to
genealogical research and census records
the records which had never been
addressed publicly by the Illinois
senator or his relatives were first
noted in ancestry report compiled by
william adams right Weisner who works at
the Library of Congress the report
carries a disclaimer that it is first
draft one likely to be examined more
closely if obama is nominated according
to the research one of obama's
great-great great-great-grandfather's
george washington overall own two slaves
who were recorded in the 1850 census in
Nelson County Kentucky also their
next-door neighbors with Mitch
McConnell's ancestors the same records
show that one of Obama's
great-great-great great-great
grandmother's married of all also owned
two slaves so it turns out that Obama
has basically the same family story as
Mitch McConnell and also opposed slavery
reparations but that wasn't why he
opposed slavery reparations obviously at
the time but for Mitch McConnell it is
the media are so corrupt and so stupid
at least members of the media
who cover this kind of stuff as news The
Washington Post covered it - it's all
insipid and it is obviously a smear and
obviously a hit shot but this is what so
many members of our media are engaged in
these days it truly is gross and stupid
we'll get to more of that in just one
second first you may know I'm on the
internet for about 24 hours per day I'm
concerned about hackers stealing my data
because of that and that's why I trust
expressvpn to protect my online activity
you should too hackers government's
internet companies basically everybody
is gobbling up your data like all of it
expressvpn runs in the background of
your computer or phone and then you use
the internet just like you normally
would you download the app click to
connect and voila you are protected by
their powerful encryption technology
I never go online without expressvpn and
you shouldn't either expressvpn is the
fastest VPN I've tried cost less than
seven bucks per month and comes with a
30-day money-back guarantee stop hackers
Big Brother Internet companies from
grabbing that data they're using that
data or why should they use that data
without your permission
take back your online privacy like I did
with expressvpn protect your online
activity today find out how you can get
three months for free at expressvpn comm
slash man that's expr ESS VPN comm slash
been for three months free with a
one-year package does it Express VPN
comm slash been to learn more go check
it out right now expressvpn com slash
ban okay in just a second we're gonna
get to the Democratic presidential race
where the media are doing incredible
work on behalf of candidates they love
and they are hatchet chopping everybody
else I'll get to that in a second first
head on over to Daley wire.com for $9.99
a month get a subscription for the
annual ninety nine dollars a year you
also get this leftist year's hot or cold
tumbler it is indeed phenomenal you will
enjoy you also get all sorts of benefits
including two additional hours of the
show every single day we are working
hard for you so go check us out over at
Daley wire.com all sorts of great things
Sundays special coming up this Sunday is
really first-rate you're gonna get it on
Saturday if you happen to be a daily
wire subscriber all sorts of goodies go
check this out we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as is evident from Mitch McConnell
and their coverage of Mitch McConnell's
ancestors going back for generations and
this is now obviously the reason that he
feels the way that he feels about a
current political issue today
I mean it's such an astonishingly stupid
and perverse and corrupt and sick way of
doing politics to go back to something
no one can control namely their ancestry
and then declare that inevitably based
on that ancestry that is probably why
they hold the positions that they do
today
it's so divisive and so cruel and so
terrible and so inconsistent and as I
say Barack Obama had slaveholders in the
family tree two of them Kamala Harris
apparently according to her dad had
slaveholders in the family tree by the
way I will note also that Snopes Wright
did a fact check on the claim that
Kamala Harris had slaveholders in the
family tree and they labeled it unknown
and suggested that right-wing purveyors
of doubt were putting out that
information
no Donald Harris commonly Harris his
father put out that information so are
we to take him at his word or no
apparently not if it does not cut in
Kamala Harris's favor snopes.com and
their fact-checking well done guys just
really strong stuff when the media have
an agenda they are willing to push it
however they can right now in the 2020
race their agenda is to knock Joe Biden
out so there are a couple new polls that
are out today
Joe Biden is still leading the field but
those polls are obviously narrowing and
that is a problem for Joe Biden the
latest poll is an emerson poll that is
out today and it kind of shows what
polls have been showing for the last
couple of days
Biden continues to have a substantial
lead he is at 30% according to Emerson
he's at 30 but there are three
candidates who are tied at 15 and that's
a problem for him because if he's at 30
they ain't all gonna be at 15 by the
time these primaries roll around IP
budda judge by the way you want to talk
about somebody who's been inflated by
the media Buddha judges it I mean Buddha
judge raised a fortune a fortune and he
is good on the stage he is a good talker
Buddha judge I've talked about this
before but he is averaging 5.3 percent
in the polling I mean this is not
somebody who's cracked double digits in
one poll in the last month and a half as
far as I'm aware in the last several
polls he's at five six eight
four for six for a soapie buddha judge
is is really not a top contender right
now there are four top contenders in the
Democratic Party does her Biden Harris
Sanders Warren Harris Sanders and Warren
are all splitting 45% of the vote as
Sanders continues to recede well you
will probably see is that support bleed
over to Elizabeth Warren and you may
start to see Kamala Harris continue to
rise if black voters start to bleed over
to Harris so I think that it's a
three-person race it may be a two-person
race between Biden and Harris if this
continues the two latest polls Emerson
has Biden at 30 and then the other three
candidates tied at 15 Politico has Biden
at 31 Bernie Sanders at a solid 19
Elizabeth Warren at 13 and Kamala Harris
at 14 points there's a poll out today
that showed actually that among 2016
Bernie Sanders voters Elizabeth Warren
was now the favorite candidate which is
sort of sort of fascinating in any case
it is obvious that many members of the
media want to see Joe Biden go down
they're not interested in Joe Biden
being the candidate so here's a CNN
panel saying the Joe Biden is out of
touch he's obviously out of touch out of
step with the far left of the party
there's no question about that and the
challenge often for Democrats in these
kind of elections is the primary base is
further to the left than the general
election primary voter and independent
so it's always a hard line to walk if
you're really focused on the general
election no different for Biden than
anybody else okay so this is going to be
the repeated line and Joe Biden is
feeling it so Joe Biden was on CNN last
night and she was forced into the
position of trying to defend her husband
from charges of racism and this is going
to be basically Biden's job from here
until the end of the primaries that is
not the position you want to be in if
you are Joe Biden defending the
plurality of the black vote in the
Democratic primaries that you currently
hold here's Joe Biden trying to explain
that that Joe Biden is not a racist and
there's one glaring absence in this
quote that that will make itself
apparent I mean the one thing you cannot
say about Joe is that he's a racist I
mean he sneaked got into politics
because of his commitment to civil
rights and then to be elec
dude with Barack Obama and then someone
is saying you know you're a racist as
soon as I heard there was a you're not a
racist I words I thought uh what's
coming next and I think the American
people know Joe Biden they know his
values they know what he stands for and
they didn't buy it
okay so Jill says well he served with
Barack for eight years where's Barack
where is he
where's Michelle she wouldn't comment on
this Joe Biden has a problem so the same
media that is attempting to take down
Mitch McConnell many of them are very
eager to watch Joe Biden burn as long as
he's not the nominee as soon as he
becomes the nominee then of course
things switch on him the rest of the
Democratic Party continues to run
dramatically to the left Elizabeth
Warren who is attempting to grab that
Bernie Sanders base and successfully
wresting away at least double-digit
support Elizabeth Warren reiterated
yesterday that she wants to
decriminalize border crossing which
would effectively mean that if you cross
the border illegally in the United
States you get to remain forever because
we would not we now have no grounds for
deportation absent some other law
breaking I assume yes or no repealing
13:25 of immigration are you in favor of
that so I am I think that the whole
notion of criminalizing the approach to
coming across the border without
documentation it's not making anybody
any safer and that we just need to be in
a different position on this okay so
Elizabeth Warren's claim there that we
need to be in a different position on
illegal immigration is a very very
radical plan and not particularly
surprising not particularly surprising
because Elizabeth Warren is indeed a
radical she's out raising Bernie Sanders
by the way in the last quarter she out
raised Bernie Sanders 19 point 1 million
dollars she raised in three months that
is not in a huge election hall at this
point but it does place her firmly in
the top echelon of the democratic money
race according to the New York Times she
had raised just 6 million in her
campaigns first three months and it had
caused some people like me to write her
off and she obviously was not to be
written off two candidates have
reportedly top twenty million dollars in
the second quarter peabody judge raised
25 million dollars in the second quarter
to be it
five percent in the polling and Joe
Biden collected 22 million Sanders
brought in 18 million dollars in the
quarter Kamala Harris really lagging
behind a 12 million although that is
going to uptick significantly next
quarter it's not just Elizabeth Warren
who is moving radically to the left Bill
DeBlasio who has no shot in this
presidential race at all he came out
yesterday and he suggested that he
basically wants to stop privatization of
education like no more private schools
if you can get away with it that if he
can get away with it he would like to
get rid of public funding for charter
schools many of which have been the most
successful schools in his own area of
New York Bill DeBlasio going full Comi
here I'm going with you I am angry about
the state of public education in America
I am angry about the fact that you are
disrespected on a regular basis in this
country despite doing such important
work I am angry about the privatize errs
I am sick and tired of these efforts to
privatize a precious thing we need
public education I know we're not
supposed to be saying hate our teachers
taught us not to I hate to privatize as
I want to stop them okay so that is
again where the Democratic Party is if
that's where the Democratic Party is and
that's where the media are then Joe
Biden has some serious trouble on his
hands the good news for Joe Biden is
that now there is another candidate in
the race he's gonna draw a significant
support I'm talking of course about Tom
Steyer the billionaire now I know we
lost Eric's wawel yesterday and that's
really sad because we are all Eric's
wha-whoa Eric swallow dropped out he is
out his campaign lasted a grand total of
91 days but it felt like longer than
that frankly because every moment Eric's
wall was on stage was an eternity but
now we have a new candidate jumping in
it's just what we need it's Tom Steyer
who's already spent hundreds of millions
of dollars on quixotic
campaigns to fight climate change while
flying around in his private jet Tom
Steyer is now going to spend another
hundred million dollars presumably
running for president on the basis of he
likes the environment and he launched a
campaign ad in which he trotted out
apparently he rated bethe O'Rourke's
wardrobe he went he got a pair of faded
jeans and a blue shirt and then he like
rented a ranch that he looks like a man
of the people and he's out there a
Ranchin with his billions of dollars
here's here's
stires bizarre strange ad launching his
presidential campaign which will garner
presumably the support of his immediate
family I think what people believe is
that the system has left them
I think people believe that the
corporation's have bought the democracy
that the politicians don't care about or
respect them
don't put them first are not working for
them but are actually working for the
people who have rigged the system we've
got to take the corporate control out of
our politics all these issues go away
when you take away the paid opposition
from corporations who make trillions of
extra dollars by controlling our
political system what are we care about
we care about proving the world and
handing it on to the next generation in
ways that they can lead better lie is so
inspiring and by inspiring I mean I'm
almost falling asleep watching this I
can't I can't wait i mean so glad that
there is just it like a random line
high-fiving people what's hilarious
about that particular shot right there
is that it is obvious that this line is
not there for him right it's obviously a
gay pride parade and he just kind of
shows up in his high-fiving people it's
like they're all here for me and they're
all looking in the other direction and
there is just high five and randos now
like we have no idea who you are or why
you are here really really spectacular
stuff good job there Tom Styer so I'm
glad we needed more people in this
particular Democratic race it is very
important that we have more candidates
without more candidates what exactly
were we going to do so Tom Steyer
Godspeed to you sir Godspeed
okay so meanwhile Kirsten Gillibrand is
still hanging out over there and she I
think she'll exit the race pretty soon I
don't think the Kirsten Gillibrand can
last very much longer despite the fact
that the Washington Post is trying to
pump her up with a piece called why
America is ignoring Kirsten Gillibrand
it's a very easy answer because she's
the worst forward answer because she's
the worst that's why according to the
Washington Post the ignoring of Kirsten
Gillibrand is happening because she is
boring she says in 2019 is by an appeal
in 2019 is unforgivable for a
presidential candidate to be boring
maybe that's our loss the problem is not
that she's
the problem she's held every position on
every issue that she is grading beyond
all imagination and that she will not
stop being kirsten gillibrand hey you
can't watch a clip of Chris chinchilla
Brown without understanding why
everybody is ignoring her here's Kirsten
Gillibrand explaining that should be
better than Joe Biden would be to take
on Donald Trump
do you think that Joe Biden waited too
long to apologize you know that's not
for me to decide I just know why I'm
running and I think I'm the better
candidate to take on president Trump
because my history is I take on the
fights that other people don't I've
stood up to the Pentagon twice first
over the repeal of Don't Ask Don't Tell
and then over sexual violence in the
military I stood up to my party when
they're wrong and you have to be able to
stand up to fight for what's right even
when it's hard especially when it's hard
and that's why I'm the best candidate to
take on President Trump and to govern
this country moving forward why are
people ignoring her because him she's
eminently ignoring
unlike Elizabeth Warren or Kamala Harris
she is eminently ignore both at is why
she's being ignored okay time for some
things I like and then a bevy a
cornucopia of things that I hate you
come back from vacation there's a lot to
hate and so we've got we got to do some
things that I hate some things that I
like over the over the vacation I was
getting up very very early and making my
kids breakfast because they decided it
would be fun to wake up at 5:45 every
single morning and so I would wake up
and they would sit there and they would
read books and I would watch TV frankly
and and cook breakfast for them and one
of the movies that I watched while I was
doing this was a movie called the
standoff at Sparrow Creek got very
little attention or anything as in
theaters and pretty sure was only
available on demand the basic premise of
the film is that there is a militia
group that receives a call that a
militia member has shot up a bunch of
police officers and then they gather
together because they're afraid that the
police are gonna come after them even
though they're not responsible and they
realize that at least they think one of
them committed this crime the movie is a
really really good type kind of black
box thriller one of the things that I
really enjoy our movies that can be done
basically with no budget and this is a
movie that was done with no budget and
you can tell it was done with no budget
I also tend to like claustrophobic
movies movies that are written you you
really have to write a great movie
in order to make it work within the
confines of a couple of sets so for
example 8 Cloverfield Lane the first
three quarters of that film is just
phenomenal it's just phenomenal because
all taking place with about three
characters four characters in I think
it's three characters in a very small
space this is done with basically five
characters six characters in a very
small space so it's about these guys
trying to figure out which one of them
did it should they turn them over to the
police
here's a little bit of the preview about
30 minutes ago a gunman opened fire on a
crowd of people it was a cop's minimum
common cash get cop in attendance
he got away go shooter shooter got away
they're saying the shooter was some
militia man contact the other militias
nearby telling we didn't do it okay so
now the remaining cops in the inevitable
military reinforcements are searching
for us we should get rid of anything
that can link us to issue
what's missing who's got it it's it's an
actor's showcase it really is quite good
it got very mixed reviews I think mainly
because it doesn't take the militia with
with the sort of lightheartedness I
think that the media wish to treat
militia groups with like it treats the
character seriously it does point out
that many of them are what Hillary
Clinton would call deplorable is not
like Donald Trump voters but actually
like one is a former white supremacist
and all of this but it's it's got some
really interesting twists and turns go
check it out the standoff at Sparrow
Creek okay time for some things that I
hate
okay so thing that I hate number one
there is this new trend I don't know why
young people are apparently incredibly
stupid there's a new trend of people who
are who are destroying products that are
on the shelves at supermarkets simply
out of pure nihilism it feels like
softcore Clockwork Orange basically and
people just running around and doing
things to hurt other people for no
discernible purpose one of these videos
was making the rounds on Twitter
yesterday young fellow who was
apparently opening up in Arizona iced
tea spitting in it is disgusting and
then closing it back up and putting it
back on the shelf and smiling about it
what what a delightful delightful human
being I can only hope that that person
is captured and then goes to jail
there's an article over at the New York
Times today by person in Ferris Stockman
says a man licked a carton of ice cream
for a viral internet challenge now he's
in jail says it started with a video of
a teenage girl licking a carton of Blue
Bell ice cream in a store and then
putting it back on the shelf the video
which went viral under the hashtag ice
cream challenge grossed out a nation and
struck fear in the hearts of ice cream
lovers everywhere in fact actually I saw
a picture yesterday of a of a freezer
that had been locked up like you would
lock up racers and I at a grocery store
and been locked up with a sign saying
that you needed help to open the freezer
because of this idiocy now the
authorities and stores across the
country are wrestling with how to stop a
series of copycat videos made by people
committing the same crime investigators
in East Texas where the first video
originated tracked down the girl but
turned the case over to Texas Juvenile
Justice Department because she's a minor
then on
today the police in Louisiana arrested a
man who posted a video on Facebook of
himself licking a carton of ice cream in
a supermarket even though he produced a
receipt showing he actually purchased
the ice cream afterward Lenise Lloyd
Martin the third a 36 year old
unemployed man has been in jail ever
since
Lonnie Cavill a Cavalier a spokesman for
the sheriff's office and Assumption
Parish said Mr Martin appeared surprised
to be arrested mr. Cavalier said he
didn't feel like he had done anything
wrong his explanation was all I wanted
to do was be famous and I paid for the
ice cream but Martin was charged with
criminal mischief for tampering with a
product before he had purchased it and
with unlawful posting of criminal
activity for notoriety and publicity it
is indeed criminal activity to make it
appear as though you are stealing
somebody's product and then buy the
product there is one thing like I'll be
in the supermarket with my kids and my
kids want to open something and I know
I'm about to buy it so I just hand it to
my kids and they eat it I don't take it
and put it back on the shelf put it on
video and then go and buy it to create
the perception that my kids have defaced
product at a store which can help drive
down business at the store
Martin will spend at least four nights
in jail awaiting his bail hearing as he
should in Louisiana the authorities have
72 hours to bring suspects before a
judge but because of the July 4th
holiday the clock didn't start ticking
until Monday Franz Bohr Carter defense
lawyers said the authorities appeared to
be trying to make an example out of mr.
Martin in an effort to put a stop to the
flurry of ice cream licking incidents
there's a highly aggressive arrest based
on a seldom used statute that is
constitutionally questionable said mr.
Beauregard he said that the charges were
questionable because it was unclear
whether Martin had committed a crime he
said a criminalizes speech okay it is
not speech to lick ice cream and put it
back on the shelf and tape it that is
not speech that is not a form of
protected speech under the First
Amendment to the Constitution my god
people but there is something deeper
going on and it is in that quote it is
in that quote that quote is that this
person wanted to be famous all I wanted
to do was be famous and I paid for the
ice cream if all you want to do in life
is be famous and you don't care whether
it's for doing something stupid or doing
something notorious and then you will
earn Fame and you should earn humanity
but there is a there's a soullessness
to people who are doing it this kind of
stuff now is this supremely prevalent no
it's not it's not but the fact that this
stuff
is being imitated at all that there are
copycat errs who are out there doing
this sort of stuff should be disturbing
to anyone and it shouldn't be laughed
off as well you know this is just
something young people do it's stupid
first of all it's actually dangerous
right I don't know what kind of diseases
people have when they're putting their
mouths in other people's food and then
putting it back on the shelf and it's
dangerous for businesses because now you
have created the perception that any
package of ice cream that I open may in
fact be two-faced but beyond that what
is going on in the heads of people who
are so concerned about Fame that they
forget about your basic duty I'm working
on a manuscript right now that is
tentatively titled rights and duties all
about the fact that we have spent so
much time in America focusing on rights
that we've spend very little time
focusing on duties and the flip side of
rights are duties you're your right to
free speech is protected by my duty not
to inhibit your free speech your right
to property is is protected by my duty
not to violate your property rights
right every right has a concomitant duty
and we've spent a lot of time in this
country not focusing on the virtues that
have to be instilled in a population in
order to protect rights if you want
rights to be protected and true rights
the right to do what you want then we
also have to have a population that is
not going to let Liberty descend into
licentiousness we have to have a
population that is not going to allow a
perception of you can do whatever you
want to devolve into I can do whatever I
want even if it harms other people or
even if it's bad for me or even if it's
bad generally and I'm in favor of a
government that stays out of everybody's
business that I get to swing my fist
around until I hit you in the nose but I
don't want a society of people swinging
their fists around because there will
lead to more bloody noses the fact that
there are more people who are doing bad
things even if it's not hurting other
people eventually the argument is and I
think it's correct that will lead to
more people doing bad things that do
hurt other people that doesn't mean the
government should come in and regulate
people waving their fists around without
hurting anybody else it does mean that
we should be inculcating a culture where
we disdain this sort of stuff that we
should be inculcating a culture where we
look at how people act and we do make
judgments social judgments about how
they act now we have created this
bizarre era sets of
- it's weird air sense virtue where
virtue lies in being yourself and being
yourself is the measure of all things
being authentic is the measure of all
things your duty lies to yourself
doesn't lie to others true duty lies in
fulfilling your own desires and longings
it doesn't lie in your duty to society
or the common good or others and this is
led to an argument that's been made by a
lot of conservatives including my friend
Saurabh Amari over at the New York Post
and his argument has been that
liberalism itself that Liberty and and
liberalism the idea of a small
government liberalism that that
inevitably could lead to a
licentiousness that undermines
liberality itself it undermines your
rights because as people start to act
worse and worse people want more and
more government regulation I think that
there is something to that argument but
I think that the balance was struck by
the founders who said we have to have
strong social institutions that
inculcate virtue and morality and
decency in people John Adams is quote
about this which I still think is the
best quote on this where he said that
our Constitution was made only for a
moral and religious people that's
correct that is in its heart correct if
you want to live in a society with
others you have to have a common
framework of responsibility and that
doesn't have to be crammed down by
government it has to be voluntarily
undertaken by people who care about each
other enough that they don't go around
licking ice cream and putting it back on
the shelves so I understand this is a
deep read on what is obviously a stupid
juvenile prank but there is a seething
roiling feeling that you own nothing to
anybody in your society unless the
government orders you to do it and
that's very dangerous because then the
government becomes the be-all-end-all
number one and number two it makes you a
worse person because the stuff that
makes you a better person is exercising
your free will exercising your free
choice to help others and live in a
society where you are doing good for
somebody else as opposed to trying to
get famous and be notorious for doing
something anything as we again start to
measure ourselves by by our beliefs
about ourselves not by beliefs of others
we become worse the self-esteem movement
has been something terrible for the
United States there's this this notion
that was put out
the 1950s 1960s that self-esteem was the
reason that crime was occurring that the
rise in crime was tied to low
self-esteem oh we had to do his boost
self-esteem in order to lower crime
rates if we wanted less bad behavior we
needed to boost self-esteem it turns out
that precisely the opposite is true
sociopaths have extraordinarily high
self-esteem self-esteem is not in any
market way tied to whether you're a
criminal or not in fact lower
self-esteem a feeling that you have not
achieved enough is very often tied to
achievement a michu so-called tigerman
professor of regale she's talked about
the idea that cultures that actually
inculcate a feeling of shame for lack of
achievement tend to be more successful
that self-esteem is not part of the
equation that earned self-esteem is
important but achievement is important
and that you can earn that that
self-esteem in a number of ways
including helping out other people in
your community but in a society that has
disdain shame in a society that says
that shame is no longer good or right
that shame itself is part of the problem
it that true virtue lies in disdaining
shame that when people say to you you're
doing something wrong maybe you should
think about how you're acting your first
reaction should be screw you I'm being
me a society that disdains that is
building a society of people who whose
only judge of morality is how many
Twitter followers they have or how many
Facebook followers they have or how many
Instagram views they have and that's
going to lead to depression it is going
to lead to a feeling of worthlessness
you know why because this is worthless
it's worthless why does any of that
matter why would Fame without any regard
for the reason for your fame be
something worth pursuing
especially here it's not gonna make the
guy rich it's not like he's gonna get
any ancillary benefits from being famous
it's almost like people who are who are
writing their names
underneath graffitiing their names on a
subway station in order to feel as
though they have left their mark there
are a couple of ways to leave your mark
and in real ways in the world one is to
be incredibly destructive and what is to
be incredibly creative to help other
people to be part of that social fabric
to rebuild communities the
individualistic atomism that's been
promote
by social liberalism in our culture is
really dangerous stuff and we tend to
think of it as fulfilment and freedom
but the idea of freedom was always tied
to the notion that we were going to take
care of each other on a voluntarist ik
basis we were going to build together
that we didn't need government to tell
us what to do we took pride in the fact
that we could get together and build
things that doesn't mean we were perfect
but it does mean the mentality was
better than the mentality is now the
mentality now is if the government
doesn't prohibit it then I am allowed to
do it nay it is promoted that I do it
the government is tasked with
inculcating its own peculiar sense of
what is right and what is wrong but you
are not only under no obligation to do
that you are basically prohibited from
even enacting your private morality in
public with others on a voluntary basis
then that leads to a generation of
people who really are kind of lost
that's that's what I'm seeing out there
and I think that it's it's dangerous we
need a return to virtue virtue is not a
word that gets set a lot anymore but we
need to talk about virtue and we need to
talk about duty and I'm not talking
about the government imposing it from
above in fact the reason that I want
virtue and duty to return is that we
don't have to have a government imposing
all of this stuff from above if Liberty
turns into licentiousness licentiousness
licentiousness pretty clearly and
obviously turns into tyranny already
we'll be back here a little bit later
today with a lot more content two
additional hours we'll see you then i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Klavan show alleged crap
stain Jeffrey Epstein has been arrested
again for allegedly raping and pimping
allegedly underage girls like the
alleged scumbag he allegedly is as a
result Epstein's Wikipedia entry is
being rewritten to edit out Epstein's
good pal Bill Clinton and labor
secretary Alex Acosta is being set up as
the sole scapegoat because a cost that
provides a tenuous connection between
Epstein and Donald Trump the coverage of
this story is going to reveal who among
journalists and politicians cares about
the truth and who only cares about
preserving Democrat power will talk
about it on the Andrew Klavan show I'm
Andrew Clavin